it was supposed to be a day of celebration is
a tragedy a car that
got into the procession we saw decorations flying
everywhere
here it was horrible
here had a large collection there
were between 150 and 200 people it
seems  he and follow them I have a
car came up from behind at
high speed and came back in
stride continued on its way for a
few hundred meters
yes as I speak to you there are six
people dead
so there  there are ten others who are
seriously injured and for some of them a
lot of concern for the future and
about twenty injured less seriously
so the impact is enormous when
you put all this together well we are around
forty people it's a
disaster  that little qualified as
a national disaster I was in my
bed just to hear the car go by
my house
frankly shook and a few seconds after
the impact on the carnival group
frankly they were not going slowly
and could  is there keep going seems so
what did I do I went down
since my children were also there
frankly I'm not telling you my
blood pressure that we were going to go up
frankly I called quickly is
what I did I  I quickly phoned
my daughter to see if she answered me
even then not unfortunately but
here she answered me well saying
here is a moment don't worry
we were on the side but she
had others who didn't  didn't have that chance